in a massive and deadly fire overnight
swept through a London apartment our
witnesses described people trapped
inside screaming for help
so far six people are confirmed dead but
the death toll could go much higher the
intense fire sent flaming debris raining
down from the 24 storey building onto
the residential neighbourhood below
flames and smoke could could still be
seen nearly 12 hours after the fire
started dozens of people are
hospitalized this Tower is located just
west of Kensington Palace and the heart
of London Jonathan Vigliotti is near the
scene right now Jonathan good morning
what can you tell us good morning we're
standing about a block away from the
building and you can see at this hour
most of it still remains engulfed in
smoke
most of the flame has been put out but
several apartments are still ablaze you
need to remember this when this fire
happened it happened in the middle of
the night with hundreds of people inside
likely asleep at the time
[Music]
the flames moved fast the wall of fire
trapping people inside cell phone video
captured their desperate attempt to
escape the 24 story inferno some waved
flags hoping firefighters would spot
them another scream for help to those
outside witnesses described the chaos
people were just waving on the top floor
I can't do nothing just screaming people
throwing themselves out just so they
don't get burnt and how high up was this
high off has passed
eighth floor there was people jumping up
from their kids they just wanted someone
if you could not save me please save my
children Alena had said friends of hers
and their five children were unaccounted
for
sixteen-year-old Ynez was asleep at the
time and made it out with her family
only to watch helplessly along with
hundreds of others as their homes were
destroyed you can see flashlights
because it was dark
you see flashlights from the windows
showing that people were still at home
people screaming banging on the wing
witnesses say the fire started on one of
the lower levels of the building around
one o'clock in the morning and within an
hour engulfed most of the more than 120
homes hours later smoke still poured
into the sky as firefighters were able
to bring one man out alive and that man
is very lucky we have been here for
several hours and he is the only person
we have seen firefighters pull from this
building alive we spoke with several
witnesses who said initially when this
fire happened firefighters actually told
them to stay indoors and to put towels
underneath their door to prevent smoke
from coming inside at this point it's
unclear what caused this fire why it
spread so quickly the Mayor of London
speaking out saying there are some
serious questions that need to be
answered
Noora lots of questions yes Jonathan
Vigliotti on the scene there in London
thank you